aujourd'hui je vous raconte la folle
histoire du monopoly un jeu volé à sa
créatrice est totalement détournées
l'histoire remonte à 1981 lorsqu'un
loterie ces activistes elisabeth maggie
imagine un jeu destiné à sensibiliser le
public aux risques du capitalisme elle
entend ainsi dénoncer l'oppression des
rentiers de l'immobilier sur les
locataires le land lors du game
littéralement le jeu du propriétaire ne
connaît pas le succès espéré et
disparaît de la circulation le concept
refait surface en 1935 en pleine grande
dépression sous l'impulsion de
l'ingénieur charles d'arc au pied est
entièrement détournée le land lors du
game devient le monopoly son but se
mettre en situation de monopole
immobilier le succès est planétaire et
charles darrow est le premier concepteur
de jeux à devenir millionnaire le nom
d'elisabeth maggie est quant à lui
complètement écartée du concept pendant
plusieurs décennies avant d'être
réhabilité au début des années 2000